Americans are less religious than ever
so why have so many recent political
speeches sounded like sermons religion
and Christianity are the biggest things
missing from this country do you know
when someone's trying to manipulate you
it's not always easy especially when
that person is supposed to be a trusted
source of
news God created
government democracy is staged with the
help of media that work as propaganda
machines unfortunately
and this is extremely dangerous to our
Democracy stand up speak out and pray
that God will bless America again Christ
not Congress will be what saves this
country and I think you all should get a
copy of God Bless the USA Bible now and
help spread our Christian values the
only border we need to secure is that
between church and state I said what I
[Music]
said all right welcome back to another
LED live with Samuel Tucker welcome to
the show again yes yes good to be back
we are discussing church and state and
we are going to talk about how the
United States is potentially walking
into this same pathway that we have seen
in history happen
before is this a good thing is this a
bad thing you will want to know this
information because where it sounds like
a great thing um we want God we want God
in everybody's life but God has never
forceful he's never he's never like you
have to do this otherwise there's going
to be consequences and I think when you
start placing the conversation in that
field bad things happen very bad very
very bad how are we going to walk into
this yes so a lot of it and as we're
going to see a lot of it is through
manipulation a lot of it is through
manipulation so it's it's a process that
the ruling Elite of really every
civilization has used in order to make
the populace to coign with what they try
to do and so we're going to get into
some of that you know in our last
session we were talking about the
influence of Roman Catholicism the
church and state with Constantine and
the reason why that's so necessary and
especially for our listeners you know
that uh didn't watch that I would we
would highly encourage you to go back
and look at that because that that
really sets the groundwork for the
psychology behind why the things today
are going the way they're going because
there there's like two factions you have
people who sincerely want morality and
proper Christian principle in society
and then there's a larger faction
especially among those that are leading
this movement who have the power that
are not doing it because necessarily
they love Christ but because they want
the Earthly power that comes with it and
so I will see some of that so on the
screen here uh this is a symbol of
something called social engineering I
don't know if we're familiar with that
concept of social engineering so as I'm
pretty sure AR audience can see this is
the this ideology of left and right you
know it's been coined as the hegelian
dialectic and it's very interesting just
again the iconography you can see here
at the cage at the very bottom what's in
the cage is freedom so you have a puppet
master you have a person that's being
manipulated with his left and right and
true
freedom is in the cage and it's amazing
because the book of Isa Isaiah actually
talked about this that he that you know
departed from Evil would make himself a
prey and so you know we even see this
from a Bible standpoint but yeah we're
just going to go over at least initially
a lot of the forces that are being used
to manip manipulate the the consciences
of men to get to this point of wanting
this Fusion of of the church and state
so this is one by the name of Marilyn
Ferguson she was an occult writer she
wrote a very uh influential book called
The Aquarian conspiracy I don't know if
you ever heard of that book before um
she so she wrote that a leaderless but
powerful network is working to bring
about radical changes in the United
States its members have broken with
certain key elements of Western thought
and they may have even brok broken
continuity with
history and I'm just building on that
this is a symbol of television now we
know that television is one of the great
educators of modern society yeah there
there's a reason why they call it a
program no it's a programming you
exactly very good point very good point
there's a book uh called a television
and international history and especially
when as we're trying to educate
ourselves and even the work that we're
doing here here it's reading is so
essential and unfortunately we we live
in a day and age where so few of us read
anymore and you know I mentioned this
the last segment I hated reading growing
up I mean with a
passion but uh it's really impossible to
be a proper Christian and not read
because we learn about God Through the
Bible and you have to read in order to
you know in order to gain this and so uh
this says television has become to
delineate for us the boundaries of
transgressions the medium operates as a
subtle instructor with the complicity of
the audience this says uh at the bottom
there says uh the television image has
thus to come to govern the senses and
the conscience to offer an ordering of
things even to exaggerate the chaos and
orderless of things so to just make that
very clear this is a symbol of the news
media and I know that especially during
a former president uh Trump's you know
presidency this idea of fake news was
really popular mhm and while this is not
an endorsement of Donald Trump there is
a reality that unfortunately a lot of
the news media is into manipulation yeah
you can see that when you see the um the
news Clips where they're all saying the
exact same thing I me word for word for
that is that is not possible in just a
randomized telling of whatever is
happening in the world that's a script
being handed to somebody and all these
news channels repeating it exactly in
any way you have them grouped this way
oh why yeah so that's a very good point
so I got this off of a particular uh
website so this was talking about I
think in the middle was maybe kind of
neutral to the uh far left is like left
leaning outlets and to the this is like
I guess quote unquote far leaning right
Outlets you get that uh get that D which
is a matter of perspective exactly
because if you're listening to CNN all
the time you know you think everything
on the other side is completely bogus
exactly and people that are there are
people that even listen to these ones in
the middle column and they you
know it it they have opinions about
every other news network everybody's got
an opinion about every other new network
that they don't listen to well I I think
when the the assassination attempt on
Trump um happened and and it was almost
like the left leaning ones were saying
like oh yeah he just fell and I was like
how did you get that wrong like you know
what I mean like they would just even
leave out some very like you know key
word and stuff and as interesting it's
it it's crazy I thought maybe they were
grouped by ownership ownership that's a
very good point as well you know this
from a book called to kill a nation it
says the US media as with most of the
news media in other Western nations are
not free and independent they are owned
and controlled by largely conservative
corporate cartels that adhere to the
self- sovering neoliberal ideology of
international Capital so this is
essentially saying that the news media
is primarily concerned with ensuring the
financial interests of multinational
corporations that they stay in their
proper place and even on another point I
know that we're talking about church and
state but a lot of times you know what
uh we've seen Even in our travels and
speaking and I'm pretty sure you all
have seen this you know as well that
even a lot of us as Christians are not
interpreting current events in light of
the Bible but we're interpreting current
events in light of Fox News and CNN and
MSNBC and all these things good point
yeah yeah and so this happens a lot yeah
what do you mean by that
so what I mean by that is like a lot of
times when people are thinking about
politics especially from the Christian
Perspective you know they're thinking
about certain value systems and stuff
like that but like say hypothetically
you're talking about um different events
that happen you know the Trump you know
attempted you know assassination you
know people are saying that you know
this was you know prophesied this
prophetic and and and all of this and
that's not prophecy that's not prophetic
that's not in the Bible right I heard
people equating that to like the deadly
wound
and it's like what that has that has
nothing to do with that it's reversed
yeah so you have the Bible which spells
everything out and then the news is
everything as it's happening yeah and
people try to take the news and then
insert it into Bible prophecy instead of
using Bible prophecy to look for what's
in history and look for the news right
it's the other way so so to some of our
viewers what would you say like would be
a real good reason to understand
prophecy at this day and age yeah well I
would even you know uh expound on that
that not even just for this day and age
but just to be a proper Christian you
know um I'm pretty sure everyone is
familiar with uh online audience a man
by the name of um Isaac Newton you know
the very famous you know mathematician
and physicist all that um he wrote a lot
on Bible prophecy you know and he's on
record as saying that it is impossible
to be a proper Christian uh without
understanding the Prophecies of the Book
of Daniel mhm because the Book of Daniel
talks about the Messiah and the specific
time that he would come to the Earth the
very first uh you know promise of the
Gospel in Genesis
3:15 um was a prophecy that's right and
so you know it's not merely as it
relates to understanding the Democrats
and the Republicans and you know what's
happening in the US but Prophecy from
the very beginning of sin into the world
has been a compass a source of comfort
for God's people so that they could have
a source of consolation all the
confusion yes exactly TR yeah so you can
see like it would be impossible like
Daniel's um you know Nebuchadnezzar
statue it would be impossible to guess
the the the kingdoms that are going to
play out in the world in so many
thousands of years go by and it's
exactly playing out like that so yeah
for sure no yeah because um I even you
know heard you know one person saying
this is a theory that um William
Shakespeare you know wrote the Bible and
you know a friend of mine you know he
was uh having a Bible study with this
person and they went through the
prophecy of Daniel chapter 2 and then
after the Bible study you know my friend
said well do you still think that you
know William Shakespeare you know wrote
the Bible and he's like yeah I don't
think no no I don't I don't think he did
this yes so yeah so we see the point as
far as manipulation now this is a very
key um uh character this man uh is named
um Edward Beres I don't if you ever
heard of Edward brne yep Sigman Freud's
nephew exactly there you go so his very
famous book propaganda um and it's crazy
because um a lot of the people that are
part of the I guess ruling Elite if you
want to class it that way um which it
really is uh they would try to say that
uh propaganda is a good thing that
propaganda you know always needs to be
used on a population you know this is
important and so uh this is what Edward
beray says that the conscience and
intelligent manipulation of the
organized habits and opinions of the
masses is an important element in
Democratic Society those who manipulate
this unseen mechanism of society
constitute an invisible government this
is his words yeah he was really um um
instrumental in basically taking and uh
his uncle's writings about uh the
manipulation of people and then applying
that to the masses exactly and it was
very lucrative for him as well made a
lot of money all right it says
continuous interpretation is achieved by
trying to control every approach to the
public mind in such a manner that the
public receives the desired impression
it says often without being conscious of
it the American motion picture is the
greatest unconscious carrier of
propaganda in the world today so this
even piggybacks I'm uh uh you all did a
segment not too long ago about God is
not dead and all of that and again so
this is just emphasizing the point that
you know news and movies and all of
these things help to force you know feed
the public this narrative right and and
you know we've recognized for a long
time a lot of these like religious
themes that are in pop culture movies
and you know it people always have the
question like are they sitting in a room
like trying to like come up with these
ideas how can we deceive people in the
world and and you know there's no way
that all these different production
companies spread over all these
different years we're talking thousands
of people thousands of different writers
how are they having this consistent
theme of this story played out and I
really honestly believe because there is
a spiritual force behind that is IMB
these thoughts with these people and
they don't even realize where they're
coming from but I think in terms of
putting these kind of ideas out there
and combining church and state back and
putting them in chrisan films um you
know even when we talked about and
brought this up on on that segment that
talked about God's Not Dead there was
people that were like what why do you
think this is a bad thing like like how
how dare you we we need God back in the
system and um you know this is why we're
kind of having this discussion right now
is we want to understand like yes we all
truly believe that everybody needs God
but when you put God in the forceful
situation of a legislative body that's
saying believe this or there's going to
be problem exactly there there becomes a
spiritual deficit there that that we
need to understand so because that's a
possibility of happening we shouldn't
put religion in there at all because you
understand how you can't run away from
it especially living in a democracy and
we're voting someone votes from their
perspective they vote from their
ideology their their moral
if the population is largely one thought
process it's going to find its way
within government I think the problem is
when the reverse happens when the
government start when the government
starts imposing things on the people
absolutely I think that it was a bad
mistake to take the Ten Commandments out
of the schools I mean I th those are
things that everybody should I bet
identify with right like you know you
shouldn't steal from people you
shouldn't kill them you shouldn't do
these things that the whole world would
benefit from not doing those things but
you know no it's very interesting that
you because this discussion is really
great um we're actually going to find
out that not only should the Ten
Commandments not be in school but prayer
shouldn't be in school now we're go see
because a lot of the framework for how
we've understood how America should be
has been through received wisdom mhm and
the Constitution is very clear on
matters and this is why uh there was
always supposed to be proper Christian
education because how in the world can a
public school run by the state properly
teach morality and this is why having
the church you know properly spiritual
and educating the children you know
people who wanted their children to be
raised that way wouldn't have to worry
about all the immorality and all the
sexual stuff happening in the schools
where they could just have this one
sphere where it's proper and they don't
have to worry about all those nefarious
you know elements but but it's not right
I'll say it again in terms of the
Constitution neither education or that
concept of church and state are found
within it well that's a very well that's
becoming a argument uh that is used um
and especially you know for those that
do Advocate because is a very good point
it's really a misunderstanding of what
the Constitution is clearly saying
because you know when the Constitution
talks about that um at no time you know
should religion be uh used as a test for
public service and all of these things
things um per persons may try to rework
that to infuse their ideas of what they
think that means but it's very very
clear because you know again going back
to you know the understanding of
morality because true morality starts in
the heart the state can never govern in
that realm and even if a person is
Christian um the their Christianity yes
is going to influence how they make
decisions but there is a general
morality that Society has to abide by
that is not necessarily attached to
Christianity because in a Hindu Society
everyone can't kill each other everyone
can you know practice extortion everyone
can do all these things yes in principle
they're in the Ten Commandments but even
if you're in a Muslim Society everyone
can't steal everyone can't you know do
all of these things that society would
break down if they were if they were
permitted you
know and so uh continue with that point
because I know um we've um I've gone a
little past so so this is the symbol of
church and state so this has been um
modernly coined as uh Christian
nationalism so I'm pretty sure this you
know concept is you know familiar to
some of us so uh these are two authors
uh by the name of uh Andrew Wad and
Samuel Perry this is the the second man
Samuel Perry and they wrote a book um
dealing with this idea of Christian uh
nationalism so this says simply put
Christian nationalism is a cultural
framework a collection of myths
tradition symbols narratives and value
systems that idealizes and Advocates a
fusion of Christianity with American CI
uh Civic life now we know from a Bible
standpoint Christianity is not American
right Christianity is not Korean
Christianity is not you know ghanian
Christianity is the religion of God and
unfortunately um men and not just in
America have always tried to infuse
their their
cultural into the you know universality
of of Christianity and that's wrong
because it always leads the exclusion of
persons who don't adhere to that
cultural idea all right so it goes on to
talk about all these things it says at
the bottom Christianity of Christian
nationalism represents something more
than religion it says as we will show it
includes assumptions of nativism white
supremacy patriarchy and
heteronormativity along with Divine
sanction for authoritarian control
emphasizing that point of military ISM
now we're going to go through some of
this um in detail and really get an
understanding of what they're talking
about now does everybody remember this
Epoch in American so this is uh Colin
Kaepernick now principally and I know
that this created a lot of vitri off
some people loved him some people vly
hated him MH now principally him bending
uh the knee this is protected by the
Constitution but a lot of Christians
were saying that this was wrong and in
all of this now notice this this is a
man by the name of CP Bowman this is a
very um as it were prolific Christian
writer around the turn of the 20th
century very interesting what he says so
he says there is nothing Divine about
the flag only as the flag stands for
liberty and justice is it worthy of
respect sure yeah now even before notice
what he says we give our heads and our
hearts to God in our country one country
one language one flag bending the knee
is a is uh in reverences an act of
worship hence is it is an act that might
very very properly be refused on
religious grounds notice the Romans held
that the state was divine indeed the
Roman state was the chief Divinity from
which all of gods of Rome derive their
dignity but God forbid that a likee idea
should ever attach to this government in
the minds of American citizens so
unfortunately we've gotten to the place
where even the the American hierarchy
you know the American state is literally
seen as Divine so again any symbol
associated with that Divinity is going
to be venerated as if it's God itself
and so as a result of that when the man
you know was bending against the flag
and all these things people were acting
as if God himself was being attacked but
he wasn't he wasn't you know because a
lot of times there's something called
cognitive dissonance and especially a
lot of us as Christians don't realize
that the Empire of the United States is
not going to last forever I mean some
sometimes it's as if we think America is
just going to continue right right you
know yeah but the Bible is very clear
that Jesus is about to set up an
everlasting Kingdom that's not only
going to do away with the United States
but do away with Russia you know Ukraine
you know Iran all of these nations and
so we have to be in that mindset and and
understand that you can see some of that
same idealism coming out recently in the
news with uh JD Vance's wife because
she's Hindu she comes from a Hindu
family her parents are practicing Hindus
uh she's a Hindu and the
Maga tribe I guess for lack of a better
word was very upset about that and
thought that he shouldn't be picked as a
running mate because she was Hindu and
they were making very pointed comments
about you know she's not even Christian
yeah you know she's she's clearly Indian
as in from India her her cultural
heritage and they were making comments
like you know the Indians are just
trying to take this country over and you
could see very much this um Christian
nationalism that wasn't an argument when
the Catholic was President no it wasn't
and the frustrating thing is when you're
looking at all of this these are smart
people people that put out documents
like you know mandate for leadership
which is what you know helped engineer
project 2025 Heritage yeah Christian
nationalism all of this these are smart
people right very smart people so
logically if we already know that if you
want to change the direction of a Nation
you use the media mhm well then why are
they going to the legal system you want
to improve the country and you want to
improve its morality then shouldn't we
improve be improving the media MH or
maybe just just do away with it yeah
it's a very good point I mean they know
how powerful the media is instead we go
and try to maneuver
legally instead of changing the other
right right exactly or don't recognize
and say hey could this be contributing
to this
immoral sit that and I say that and and
one of the one of the things that you
know the Seven Mountains mandate is is
looks at is the Arts and entertainment
industry mhm but still it's almost like
putting the cart before the horse M well
I think it's because the two go hand
inand government and media I mean the
government influences media so heavily
that yeah if you control the government
you're essentially controlling the media
yeah I mean it's and especially you know
when we think about this idea of
Christian nationalism the Christian
nationalism will attach itself to
whatever culture it is working out of so
again we talked about you know uh Roman
Catholicism so again it's called Roman
Catholicism because the cultural
framework it was working out of was
Roman MH so you know if it was you know
uh this Christian nationalism in India
it would have this Indian cultural
framework connected to it and would have
all of these pageant trees and all that
and but it's so antithetical to
Christianity because Christianity Christ
was literally inaugurating a religion
where there was no cast no Creed no
Greek you know Jew or whatever the case
may be there was going to be one fold
and one Shepherd but you know when true
spirituality is not the focus all of
these other influences will find you
know find their way all right yeah so
continuing so these are a lot of
Advocates of the Christian nationalism
Woman by the name of margorie Taylor
green um this is a g gentleman by the
name of Doug mastriano and Laura
bobbert um uh the rise of theocracy
among conservatives so they talk a lot
about how you know uh so this is
literally from Laura barbert she says
the church is supposed to direct the
government the government is not
supposed to direct the church which is
true but the first part is incorrect
that is not how our founding fathers
intended it now maybe the false founding
fathers but the true founding fathers of
this nation would would have vly
disagreed with this reality you're going
to have to false true huh false founding
fathers true founding fathers yeah so
you know again there there's a lot of of
Miss um history that's given in regards
to the country so truthfully speaking
there were really only a num a select
few of the founding fathers especially
when you talk about all of the
individuals that influen this nation
becoming what it is that really
understood this aspect of civil liberty
you know one of them was a gentleman by
the name of Isaac beckus and he doesn't
get a lot of fanfare but he greatly
helped to influence you know what became
the Bill of Rights uh also uh Roger
Williams uh Roger Williams was a very uh
strong advocate of not only civil but
religious liberty and while you know the
Puritans we'll get into it as the
Puritans were persecuting the Baptists
and Native Americans and all these
things Roger Williams said no yes they
don't you know have our faith whatever
the case may be but they're human beings
and their religious Liberties also need
to be respected and you know he then
became the found of Rhode Island so um
while it is true obviously you know
people like Jefferson and you know
Hamilton and and Washington you know
they were used in the sense that there
were a lot of things that they
inculcated but there were a lot of
unfortunate moral contradictions with a
lot of these a lot of these men but this
is how nations are formed you know
there's good and and and and there's bad
MH all right so this is the influence of
now of overt Christianity so now some
persons of our listeners may be confused
now there's nothing wrong with
Christians wanting to um be a blessing
to politicians the Bible is very clear
in second Timothy and Romans that we
should pray for those in elected
position so that we can lead a Peaceable
life because again persons May hate
Donald Trump but Jesus died for him M
and one of the things that we really
emphasize is that it really kills me
when I see us as Christians um so
involved in this political process that
we sound like a person who doesn't know
the Lord so like we hate this politician
we hate that politician as if God's
primary concern is whether or not a
Democrat gets in office or a republican
gets in office you know it's crazy mhm
Doug mastriano is another unfortunate
point so I'm pretty sure we've all heard
of the concept of white privilege so
Doug mastriano and God bless his heart I
know that you know he wasn't
intentionally trying to be nefarious but
he said you know instead of saying White
Privilege we should call it white
blessing because of the blessing that
you know um that uh slavery was cuz it
helped to build a lot of our
infrastructure and all in in all of this
you know reality again you know he
apologized and so on and so forth and
this is not as a means to beat up our
our our dear brother but again when
we're talking about the Christian
nationalism this is unfortunately some
of the ideologies that are infused with
it as well well that might actually help
you supposed to share your
blessings you know so yeah changing the
word might change the perspective yes
but again when we're let's not just
think about this in regards to the
United States the Roman Empire was doing
the same thing when they adopted
Christianity as their official religion
mhm all right so we're getting down to
the Crux now this is a symbol of the
Puritans now part of the reason why
talking about the influence of
Catholicism was so important is because
the Puritans get a lot of their
theological framework from a lot of
Catholic
disposition so the Puritans get their
religious Heritage from a gentleman
named John Calvin now John Calvin for
some of our listeners who may know who
that is he had the greatest theological
influence on Christianity um especially
protestantism when we talk about that
but unfortunately John Calvin didn't
understand the separation a of church
and state and because the Puritans were
staunch Calvinists they brought this
understanding over to the new world and
so as a result of that this is the
Heritage that helped to found the United
States so again at Jones so this man was
an historian um Christian Theologian
around the turn of the 20th century
wrote a lot on religious liberty
especially as it relates to a Bible
prophecy a lot of lot of good good
material it says that they were uh so
persecuted talking about the Puritans
and abused by all classes as well as by
the officers of the law that in 1608
they fled to Holland and then jumping
down it says from there a company of
these pilgrims sailed and landed at
Plymouth New England in 1620 now I'm
pretty sure a lot of our listeners are
familiar with this this is some American
history that's still taught in the
middle was not here an opportunity to
establish a complete and unabridged
Puritan government so while they were
escaping religious persecution they also
wanted to establish a Puritan theocracy
here in the new world
mhm all right it says in 1629 a royal
Charter was obtained and in the middle
it says a Puritan or calvinistic
government was at once established and
put into working order so this is how
the 13 colonies were originally
established it was a fusion of church
and state a fusion of that reality
all right it says in the middle thus the
poity became a theocracy by the
fundamental law of the colony
constituted the Oracle of the of the
Divine will a commonwealth of the chosen
people in Covenant with
God and lastly it says this was the
calvinistic system precisely the
preachers were not to hold office in
itself but they were to be the rulers of
all who did so in the colonies they
might not have been the politicians but
all the politicians went to them to get
their you know policy signed off on it
says this was to make the preacher
Supreme they were consulted in
everything and everything must be
subject to their dictation that's not
very different than Catholicism exactly
exactly it's literally the exact same
thing so whether you call it Catholicism
whether you call it Christian
nationalism the principle is the same is
that why it's like image of exactly
exactly cultures don't change overnight
yes and so you know I've had this
conversation with our friend Alex gastos
you know he's from Mexico and I've been
to a lot of spanishs speaking
congregations when you go as a speaker
you'll notice you go in doesn't matter
what your background is if you're the
one speaking you're Pastor yeah I mean
that's just the way it is you're pastor
pastor Pastor huge amount of respect
right from the get-go and they don't
know you from
Adam and I've talked to him about that
and I was asking him why why is that and
it it really lined up with something I
was thinking and he's like well most of
these people their cultural heritage as
far as religiously goes back to
Catholicism yeah right and that's the
way it was you have a village the whole
village that the guy the main guy is the
priest everything revolves around the
priest whatever the priest tells them to
do it's what happens right
and so you notice how that carries over
even when they become
Protestants it's like a whole church
really revolves around a pastor you
don't have a pastor in place it's like
the whole place is in chaos it's like
they don't know what to do what to do
and and it's not to say that you know um
not to fault them for that or anything
it's just an observation like it the
pastor seems to be the glue to that
congregation yeah and and it's it's
really like kind of like when you just
observe people it's kind of like
whatever he says that's what happens
that's what it goes yeah that's a very
very good point go and it's not that
there's anything nefarious going on or
anything evil or anything like that it's
just like it's the cultural mindset like
it just has continued to carry over
where people from other cultures they
tend to maybe be more I don't know for
lack of a better word rebellious they're
like Pastor told me to do what I'm not
doing
that you there's there's less I guess
levels of respect for a position and and
other things that play in that's a very
good point and you know what's really
helped me even as you know I've grown in
just an understanding just getting older
um when you really just take time to
understand why people think the way they
do you know why you know they make
decisions like that and understanding a
lot of this history and even to the
point that you uh mentioned um it really
allows you to have more empathy more
sympathy cuz even as we talk about this
a lot of the people who agree with
Christian
nationalism many of them are not doing
the because they hate people right you
know they're not doing a lot of them are
not doing this because they're
intentionally trying to like serve the
devil and you know for his his agenda
but because of the influences that have
you know affected how they think and
operate they've been led to these
conclusions that's why forms like this
are so important to help re-educate
they're doing what they think is right
exactly exactly so I'm super curious I
know we're going to get to it but why
why can we not have the tank Pars in
prayer in church
yes yes so as as we talk about this you
know reality of church and state part of
the reason is because when we talk about
like the place of the the the Bible in
Christian education it has its place in
Christian education so you know just to
you know leave an example people are
getting up in arms in regards to JD
Vance and his wife and Hindu and all and
all these things now if we're really
going to talk about that this is a land
of proper civil and religious liberty if
we're going to make way for Christian
prayers Christian Ten Commandments by
default if we're going to be
intellectually consistent we're going to
have to make way for Hindu prayers for
Hindu Ten Commandments for Muslim and
and all of these things and so now if
you know they want to do that from
whatever type of standpoint that's one
thing but we know that that's not going
to that's not going to fly and so when
the Constitution talks about this
reality of not having religious tests
and and all of these things it was
really with the understanding that there
was to be a complete separation of this
because again A lot of times people
don't understand the framework that the
founding fathers were coming out of so
even though you know a lot of them you
know weren't completely moral in its
proper sense they were coming from
Western Europe that was dominated by you
know kingcraft MH where you know they
had this concept of the divine right of
kings so even though there was the pope
over there and even in England even
though you know after the 16th century
you know Catholicism wasn't dominating
that country the King was mhm and you
know as a result of that the King was
able to do whatever he did you know
whatever he wanted to do and and and
stuff like that and with um religion
being so infused into the state they
really wanted to ensure that that would
not once again be replayed over in the
United States this is why we have three
branches of government um you know this
is why even if you know uh tyrannical
president gets into office there's still
two other branches of government M and
so these were all safety measures that
were put in to ensure that this Fusion
of the church and state wouldn't happen
but again when we're talking about
schooling especially from a Christian
standpoint and this would even be
another subject on just Christian
education in general part of what made
the Protestant Reformation so powerful
was because Martin Luther and his
associates were not just focused upon
you know uh abdicating from the papacy
but they greatly emphasized the
importance of Education you know the
whole idea of having the Common People
educated where you know children can go
to school came from
protestantism and as the early reformers
were educating the young people
protestantism was very strong you know
there's a book uh by The Man by the name
of EA Su and called uh living fountains
or broken sisters where he talks about
that it was through education that
protestantism failed and Catholicism
triumphed that's right that's where they
found their inroad back in exactly and
so when we're talking about Christian
education it was never God's will for a
secular state to be training a young
Christian Child on how to be moral that
was always to be the the role of the
church and this is why principally
especially when you look at you know the
beginnings of of the US almost every
Church no matter the denomination had a
school attached to it Harvard y were
established as Christian institutions
they weren't secular and so um yeah so
it would be a lot of that yeah that was
sufficient yeah I I totally agree and
and you know I think that that that that
education for you know the way that you
interact with God needs to happen from
the home and from your church and yeah
it it does not seem possible that the
state can make those rules because
that's exactly the argument that the
Church of Satan came out with when when
like oh you're putting the Ten
Commandments over here well we're going
to bring our over here how you going to
tell them no and then you know so you
have to make provision for everybody
which would then all of a sudden Infuse
the religion with a ton of different
ideas but that's not what they're doing
they're not making provision for
everyone they're kicking Christianity
out and
then neutrality in this context doesn't
exist it doesn't work because at the end
of the day morality is coming from
somewhere so if you completely take out
Christianity it's it's going to come
from somewhere else we're not going to
talk about it or or what have you but
it's coming from somewhere and it's from
the other side no and and this is why
there was a general admission in the
Declaration that all men are created
equal and are endowed by their creator
with certain unalienable rights you know
the pursuit of happiness and all of this
so there was an acknowledgement that
there was a Creator but there was no
specificity given to that religious
framework the problem comes is where in
a secular State a specificity is given
to the acknowledgement of who who that
Creator is what's his name how how you
should follow him and and all of that
and so would you say it's equally as
unconstitutional to say take it out
completely wouldn't it be at the
discretion of the school or even the
teacher well if you're talking about um
specifics again if you're talking about
you know Christianity or Islam or
Hinduism or whatever the case may be
that's wrong from a constitutional
standpoint if you just want to talk
about you know General General morality
and a you know search after truth and
you know philosophy in in true
philosophy and all of that that's proper
like for
instance the Bible should be studied in
certain aspects in public school because
of its literary genius like for instance
there are many secularists who talk
about just the poetic Mastery of the
book of Isaiah so it's not even being
looked at from a religious standpoint
but just the the moral upliftment from a
literary standpoint that it gives again
you don't even have to force you know
the the the the the obligation of the
Bible but just studying it from you know
that standpoint would be very beneficial
as studying certain things from you know
Plato or you know Aristotle or Socrates
or Muslim writings and and stuff like
that do that make sense no I agree yeah
and and I agree with what you said uh in
terms of the responsibility of the
church instead of Christians trying to
force Christian beliefs within Public
Schools they should be sending their
children to Christian institutions and
as far as the government goes yeah yeah
don't kick out one if anything have an
availability of all yeah I just found it
interesting at the height of this a few
years ago they were kicking out
Christianity we bringing in New Age
they're bringing in even secularism
which is a type of different ideology
and religion for sure cuz yeah go ahead
I'm sorry yoga all that you know what I
mean those are religions and people
don't look at that it is it is so it it
it just shows the hypocrisy a lot of
times that happens so yeah so going on
with the Puritans so again as a result
of them believing that God was was
leading them to the United States and
they literally the Puritans believe that
the United States was Canaan so by
default all of the Canaanites in America
had to be leave they had to they had to
leave yes awful yes so again this was
the understanding that they had so even
the slaughter of the Native Americans it
wasn't a big deal because it was God's
prophetic will see that's that that
that's where it's like if you misapply
some of those things that happened in
the Bible it's like you can bend that
thing to say whatever you needed to say
and and and it becomes scary because
when people think that they are serving
God and doing the work of God there's no
ends to where they'll go it's true it's
true it's
true all right um so yes talk about um
Thanksgiving and kind of the myth of
that this was actually the persecution
of a Woman by the name of Mary Dyer um
she was a Quaker and you know a lot of
times especially you know when you talk
about the slaugh of the Native Americans
and slavery there's a lot of vit all
that is you know manifested because
sometimes persons feel as that they're
being attacked you know because of their
history and and and stuff like this but
again it wasn't just the you know slaves
and the Native Americans but it was also
Quakers people of different Christian
Persuasions that were persecuted by the
uh by the Puritans it's my understanding
it was the the Quakers who stood up
against slavery yes you know got a Nobel
Peace Prize for it yeah so don't get me
wrong some of them did profit off of
slavery but as a their their General
tenant was was not endorsing it yes so
that is very true that is very very true
um this is from a very powerful volume
called the Great controversy very
powerful historical treaty written
around the turn of the 20th century this
says the doctrine that God has committed
to the church the right to control the
conscience and to Define and punish
heresy is one of the most deeply rooted
of papal errors very very Dee rooted now
again some person will say well this is
just white Evangelical Christ
Christianity you know that's that's
really the problem but it's not just
that well what is this are these people
white in this congregation now you can
this you know this is a black
congregation but you can put any type of
other cultural framework in there it's
really all a collective and again you
know uh you know very many of us as
black persons you know voted for Obama
you know because he was black and
obviously because of what a lot of us as
black persons dealt with our forefathers
you can understand why there was such a
gravitation towards this I iography it
makes a lot of sense you know you're
talking about grandparents that were in
Jim Crow and slavery and all of this and
seeing a black man as the president it's
like wow like we've reached the Zenith
you know so you can obviously sympathize
and and understand that M but
unfortunately um our dear brother uh
Barack was not encouraging proper
morality and so again it's one thing
when someone doesn't know the Lord but
it's one thing again for Christians to
be endorsing these these realities
awesome yeah we'll leave a uh a link to
his YouTube page below and you've got a
lot of like awesome Evangelistic
serieses that you've done he works with
his wife his wife does cooking um
healthful living and uh they're actually
doing a little series around a church
around here right now so uh thank you
for coming by and blessing us indeed
indeed like this video share it with
somebody that you think would know or
want to know about this particular topic
and uh we thank you guys for stopping in
and watching our ministry uh if you'd
like to support Little Light Studios you
can go to our website little light
studios. TV there's a donate button
right there but uh just give it a thumbs
up and a like that's a huge help to us
and uh we thank you guys for
watching created you
Jacob and he form you
isra I will make him a pillar in the
temple of my God and he shall go no more
I will ride on him the name of my
God in the
[Applause]
[Music]
Lord Al but by everyone of that proceeds
from the mouth of God
do you have questions about the Bible
that you've been struggling to find the
answers for video Bible study or VBS for
short is a YouTube channel that answers
your Bible questions in 5 minutes or
less check out these easy to understand
comprehensive videos talking about
everything from what happens when you
die to why does God allow suffering
make it your goal to deepen your
relationship with Christ this year and
subscribe to video bible study on
YouTube to help you along your journey
[Music]